[Musique]
bienvenue au centre d'entrepreneuriat
s'appelle le 503 son entrepreneuriat de
l'institut d'optique
oddo prône ariane alors c'est une
formation de l'université paris saclay
qui est organisé par l'institut
d'optique et c'est la première édition
100% dédié au dos tant dans les
laboratoires il ya plein d'idées à
valoriser et également des gens qui se
demandent si potentiellement ils
pourraient pas créer une start up donc
l'idée c'est d'amener ces deux pleurant
à réfléchir lors de cette session qui
dure quatre jours alors quelques jours
c'est court c'est dense méthode à
apprendre beaucoup d'outils la méthode
du design thinking qui est nouvelle pour
eux puisque c'est une méthode qui est
basée sur potentiellement a besoin d'un
client ou donc besoin d'un utilisateur
et de réfléchir à des solutions
alors ces problèmes potentiels on a
demandé à des entreprises des centres
d'entrepreneuriat de nous ont préparés
quelques-uns des problématiques qui pour
pouvoir amener des solutions simples ou
pas techno coupat et qui potentiellement
vont intéresser un client qui sera prêt
à acheter acheter cette solution ça veut
dire potentiellement aussi avoir de quoi
créer une histoire
ça déroule sur quatre jours
effectivement où on alterne des phases
où
un produit méthodo et des outils qu'ils
appliquent immédiatement sur leurs
projets et on les prépare rapidement
puisque demain ils vont avoir un jury
qui va évaluer la pertinence de leur
travail de la semaine que ce soit en
terme d' équipes en termes de réponse un
problème qui a bien été identifié et
également un potentiel de avec un
business model qui pourrait tenir la
route pour comme starter la fin sera qui
a envie et qui veut poursuivre sur ces
sujets là notre projet ça a été en fait
de développer une solution pour les
personnes à qui ont des problèmes en
fête visuelle
donc soit les malvoyants et les
personnes aveugles elles ont des
problèmes en fait pour l'accès en
particulier aux piscines au niveau de la
formation en fait ça nous a énormément
apporté par ce que l'ensemble de
l'équipe est doctorante et en tant que
doctorant en fait on est
toute la journée en train de parler de
science qui sont extrêmement précises et
on n'a pas ce regard-là finalité en fait
nos recherches où on est une personne
qui va devoir l'utiliser
c'est la première fois que le fait je
trouve c'est un assez bon à
l'entraînement malgré le temps qui est
relativement court de quatre jours mais
c'est extrêmement intense et en fait on
la meilleure manière d'apprendre c'est
vraiment de le faire et cette formation
le permet donc c'est assez cool
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]